19. have we seen this before in the tour
and moved 19 in both players around the
two-minute mark
well okay well we have a super committal
decision
here david because anish don't care
he's just gone forward with his pawn and
uh
well magnus reacting reacting
immediately but is that is that the best
choice we didn't even get time to
process
the consequences of that move because
giri it looks like his pawn is pinned in
the center the
black pawn that did just move he's given
up his queen anishgiri has sacrificed
his queen
the bomb is about to explode he's just
given up his queen for a rook and a
night but suddenly black has
huge threats black's rook is striking to
drop down and
checkmate almost checkmate this white
king on the bottom row
suddenly black is the one on the attack
magnus he must have underestimated this
this one is so hard to judge but he
played his last move so quickly
so wow anish geary saving the best for
now
um and wow suddenly he's the one on the
attack all of black's pieces are working
oh my god david